so well the middle ground we came to is
this like cuz number one is like yo
we're going to cover this so you know
I'm not I'm not going to be a fan of
that and I'm a person who actually been
a victim and King knows like I've been a
victim vicious data breach in my life
you know where it really affected my
life the family a lot of things so I
know what that feeling is but you know
that now that being said like you know
like we said earlier we've always
covered data breaches you know what I'm
saying whether from journalist you call
yourself a journalist or a content
creator things of that nature and just
like we're not going to play double
standard now and and just because look
we love insomnia and not just because
it's a or it's a Sony studio you know
what I'm saying we cannot pick and
choose what we're going to talk about
because at the end of the day the the
rationale is there's so much information
that you can actually learn on how the
business Works actually works and this
coming from themselves